the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video well my
friends we finally have some new photos
from one of the sets of house of the
dragon earlier this morning dozens of
photos were released online showing many
different characters as they are filming
new scenes for house of the dragons
first season as you all know hbo is
developing a new show set in george rr
martin's a song of ice and fire universe
only this show is set roughly 170 years
before the events of game of thrones for
the handful of you that might not know
house of the dragon will show the
downfall of house targaryen as the
family fights each other over the iron
throne during what is known as the dance
of dragons
the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons
by the end we had two and nearly as few
targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again let me show you some of the
new photos that were released earlier
today in this first photo we see a young
alison hightower as she is stepping out
of a wagon
now unless this is a flashback scene we
very well could see this happen in the
very first episode of the show this is
the second actress hbo hired to fill in
for the role of queen alison since this
is the actress emily carey we know this
will be the younger version of alison
hightower so this is either a flashback
scene or one of the early episodes in
the season the actress is only 18 years
old which just so happens to be the same
age alison was when she married the king
viserys targaryen now it's hard to say
if this has happened already or not i
would like to think that her wagon would
be a lot more fancier if she was already
the queen in this scene it almost looks
as if the wagon is made out of metal
although that doesn't necessarily mean
anything either if we look at one of
these other photos we also see rhaenyra
targaryen in this scene she will be here
with allison as well this is also the
younger version of rhinera because that
is actress milly alcock i don't know
about all of you but i am definitely
getting the daenerys vibes as i look at
this image of rhaenyra now what makes
this scene even more interesting is the
fact that rhaenyra is here with her
dragon cyrax if you look at this photo
you can see rhaenyra interacting with
what will be her dragon as soon as all
the effects are added in later i'm not
exactly sure what is happening in all of
these different photos but it does seem
obvious they are on the road as they
head for a destination unknown if we
look at some of these wider shots we can
see there are a lot of different
characters here with them as well as
several more wagons following behind all
of this looks like it will be happening
in the same scene most of these photos
are of the same thing only from
different angles here we have actor
graeme mctavish fully dressed in his
kingsguard armor if you zoom in on the
photo you can see house targaryen sigil
on the horse now this actor isn't just
any old member of the kingsguard he will
be harold westerling lord commander of
the kingsguard another interesting thing
about this photo is what's behind him in
the wagon it's obviously full of bones
but if you look closely at some of them
you will see that some of those are
blackened with ash meaning that was food
for the dragons
now maybe it was food that was brought
with them specifically for the dragons
or maybe the dragons went out on their
own and did some killing and now they're
cleaning up what's left behind this
photo here of the men in black on their
horses is interesting as well the man on
the left looks like actor gavin spokes
and he very well could be lionel strong
lord of harrenhal
now depending on what year this is
lionel strong could be the master of
laws or even the hand of the king
although i do not see the badge on his
uniform my guess is this is when
allison's father serado hightower is the
hand of the king
i'm thinking this might be around the
year of 106 ac the same year in which
alicent and king viserys get married
shortly after the death of his first
wife emma aaron i say that because
harold westerling dies in the year of
112 ac so we know it's before that
because he's the commander of the
kingsguard in one of these photos i also
feel like this is before the year of 109
ac because lionel strong does not appear
to be the hand of the king although this
is all speculation
now i don't know who the hell this
character is right here he looks like
he's some sort of airbender or he's
simply some sort of sheep herder it
looks like he has a dragonglass dagger
but that doesn't seem likely for this
era there are a lot of other soldiers or
bannermen in some of these photos but i
can't fully make out which house they're
from if you look at the men in red right
here it almost looks like they have the
blackwood sigil on their armor but i
don't think that's likely obviously all
of these characters are on the road my
guess is somewhere in central westeros
but i can't be more specific than that
based on the images we have here it's
exciting finally seeing all these
characters filming scenes together again
i'm interested in seeing how they will
use some of these actors given the age
differences from the younger version of
alison and rhaenyra and the older
versions of allison and rhaenyra like i
said before they might be filming
flashback scenes or they will use these
actresses in the first half of the first
season and then maybe somewhere around
episode 5 they might say several years
later then start showing the older
actresses from there on out another
thing i'm interested in is seeing how
some of these actors look with their
dragons hopefully the dragons look as
amazing as they did in game of thrones
obviously the dragons will be much
larger than dany's was in the first
season that's for sure
now they obviously won't be as big as
drogon was near the end but they will
not be little babies either vegar on the
other hand will be massive i cannot wait
to see that dragon brought to life on
the screen
rose through the clouds and below him
the monstrous veigar
veigar was five times the size of araks
and the hardened survivor of a hundred
battles
vegar caught him above shipbreaker bay
watchers on the castle wall saw distant
blasts of flame and heard a shriek drown
out the thunder
i also hope we start to see more photos
leak out from the various sets they are
filming over the next few months as long
as they are filming scenes outside we
should get more photos during those
scenes so i am definitely excited for
that as well make sure you subscribe if
you want to stay up to date on any and
all information regarding game of
thrones house of the dragon and or a
song of ice and fire
as always i want to thank all of you for
watching the video let me know what you
think is happening in some of these
photos leave your thoughts down below
have a great day everyone i will see you
again very soon
bye
um
[Music]
you